okay thanks for that introduction elaine
and i'm glad to be here giving this vax
talk
to
mainly a student audience and
one one faculty member two okay
so um i'm going to talk about cancer
risk and prevention in people living
with hiv aids
what's that that's unfair
okay
okay so let me acknowledge up upfront
my main collaborators
uh
leslie park jan jan tate amy justice
mike silverberg lee quinn and haikun lin
um
any uh venture
research ventures these days are really
done in groups
it's not really possible to do
research on your own anymore
and there are many other people that
where that should be acknowledged in
terms of the the work i'm going to
describe couldn't have been done
without them
okay so this is basically my seminar
so number one cancer is a major cause of
morbidity and mortality in people living
with hiv aids
people living with hiv have elevated
risk for many cancer types
especially those with a viral etiology
and that's due to number one hiv
infection itself
the effects of hiv infection
um high and number two high prevalence
of non-hiv cancer risk factors
okay and then
thirdly
in terms of cancer prevention among
people living with hiv
there are three main components
one is early antiretroviral therapy or
art um to preserve and restore immune
function
second to reduction and prevalence of
non-hiv cancer risk factors
and third
screening for selected cancer types
so that's basically that's basically it
but i'm gonna i'm gonna fill in the
details uh in the remainder of the
seminar
okay so first
cancer is a major cause of morbidity and
mortality in people living with hiv
let's first think about the general
population
cancer as you're probably all aware is a
major cause of morbidity and mortality
in the general population and i'll focus
on mortality um
if we could if we could demonstrate you
know a major mortality kind of you know
knowing about cancer means there's also
a lot of morbidity involved
so with this slide i adapted from the
latest data from the national center for
health statistics on
mortality in the united states
and which is from 2010
um so this is proportion of mortality
for three different causes
accidents heart disease and malignant
pleasants and proportional mortality is
just the percent of all deaths so for
example among people in the age group 15
to 24 years
more than 40 percent of deaths
were due to accidents
okay so it's just asking what are people
dying from it's not looking at rates
just saying what are people dying from
so
you can see that accidents are very
important in the younger
age groups
with kind of declines and
importance at least with regard to
proportion of deaths
cancer and heart disease as you're all
aware aren't all that important
although
in young people although
to some degree they are
but what i wanted to point out in
particular
is in this
this group particularly from age 45 to
74.
let's call it middle age
cancer is the main cause of death
it's not it's not usually appreciated
if you look at all ages heart disease
beats out cancer by a bit although
cancer has kind of been moving up and
it'll probably surpass heart disease
within the next five years or so
but you know if you look at 6 55 to 64
and 65 to 74 in particular
more than a third of deaths and that
important those important age groups are
due to cancer okay so cancer is clearly
a major cause of mortality in the
general population
now what about in the hiv population
well first let's take a little
digression
and classif there's kind of a classical
cl
classification system for cancer and hiv
we have our aids-defining cancers which
we'll call adc for short
and those are caposi sarcoma
non-hodgkin's lymphoma and invasive
cervical cancer
and then all of the other cancers are
non-aids defining cancers
okay
how many i'm just curious how many of
you are familiar uh with the natural
history of hiv
okay most of you so i'll go through this
fairly quickly
um
okay so we have
primary infection
this point here someone actually becomes
infected with hiv
initially
this axis shows cd4 lymphocyte counts
okay so that's this
this axis shows hiv rna copies copies
per milliliter in the blood
on a log scale
so that's this
so initially we have a big drop in cd4 a
big rise in hiv
rna
but then the immune system
kicks in and is able to control the hiv
to some degree so we see a drop in the
hiv rna
some recovery in cd4
then we see a long period might range
from 8 to 12 years let's say
where someone's infected but
but pretty much totally asymptomatic
it's a silent infection
and then
eventually the immune system loses
starts losing the struggle with the
virus
and so
virus increases cd4 decreases
and at a certain point we have the end
stage of hiv disease which which is aids
as you all know and in the absence of
treatment with art
once a person develops aids their life
expectancy is probably a year or two
okay
so we could define aids as hiv sero
positivity and
either a cd4 cell count less than 200 or
one or more aids defining conditions
which the cdc has established and we
could put those into three categories
opportunistic infections cancers and i
can
and other i couldn't figure out
anything else to call them
um
so and in the pre-art era most people
living with hiv died of aids that was
the cause of death
um they might have died of a car
accident you know before they could die
of aids but generally would be aids
all right so just real quickly then the
aids defining conditions so let's
dispose of the other first so those are
the other
then
we have our opportunistic infections i'm
just showing these briefly um just
um so there are a bunch of opportunistic
infections specific ones that are
considered aids defining
fung as you know fungus infections
they're viral infections bacterial
infections protozoa like all could be
opportunistic infections
okay and then we have our asefining
cancers as i mentioned earlier there are
three of them
and it so happens that each one of them
is caused by a virus
so ks is caused by chaos-associated
herpes virus which we'll call kshv
non-hodgkin's lymphoma
the subtypes that are particularly
associated with hiv are caused by
epstein-barr virus or ebv
and insert invasive cervical cancer is
caused by human papilloma virus
hpv okay so those are the art aids to
finding cancers
so
in terms of cause of death
in the art era
we've seen a pretty dramatic shift so
in the pre-art era pretty much
everyone's dying of aids
now we're seeing a substantial increase
in life expectancy
an increase in non-aids comorbidities
heart disease kidney disease liver
disease and cancer
and therefore a shift in the cause of
death spectrum towards non-aids defining
causes including the non-aids defining
cancers
okay
so now let me show some um
of our data
uh this is from the veterans aging
cohort study
also known as vax
amy justice is the pi of that cohort uh
which is based at the west haven va but
it's a national cohort as i'll explain
in a minute
and i'm going to talk in particular
about the vax virtual cohort
it's totally assembled from national va
databases there's no contact with
patients
so this this is all of the
the cohort includes all people
in the va medical system for hiv care
okay so it's a it's a large cohort
um
it's um
the linkage among the databases is
accomplished uh because there's a
personal identifier
which is the scrambled social security
number
so so
we have pharmacy databases laboratory
results databases
cancer registry as i'll mention later
inpatient encounter database outpatient
encounter and so all those could be
linked together and then you could
follow these people electronically again
there's no contact but everything's done
electronically
and the cohorts periodically updated
right now there are approximately forty
eight thousand hiv infected and ninety
six thousand hiv uninfected
whoops this should have said uninfected
um
matched to the infected uh by age sex
race ethnicity and va site
okay
okay so
we looked at time trends and cancer
mortality among men in the vaccinational
court the reason it was we restricted it
to men is that 98 of the cohort is men
um
and
so we did this by linking facts with the
national death index from which you
could obtain cause of death uh from the
death certificate so you this gives you
the cause of death information on the
death certificates
median observation time was 6.4 years
for the infected 8.3 years for the
uninfected and there were total of over
27 000 deaths in the cohort that
occurred
between 1996 and 2009
okay
so first simply look at time trends in
cancer proportion mortality
so
hiv uninfected hiv infected
four different time periods
and we're looking at the proportion of
deaths that were from cancer
okay so you can see for
the uninfected um
it was fairly stable around 25
across the periods but for the infected
we see a rise in the proportion of
deaths
from cancer from about a little over
fifteen percent to about twenty three
and a half percent
okay now if we look at
the aids of finding cancers in
particular
we see that proportional mortality is
fairly low
for the hiv uninfected
for the hiv infected we see a drop over
this time period from about over seven
percent to about three and a half
percent so it drops in half
for the aids defining cancers
in terms of proportion of deaths
okay and then the non-age to finding
cancers
again fairly stable in the uninfected
see arise from about seven and a half
percent of deaths
to about 18
of deaths
uh
during this time period
okay now what about mortality we're
we're rates that we were just looking at
so far we've just been looking at the
proportion of deaths
uh from cancer that tells us nothing
about mortality rates
so now this is looking at um
cancer mortality rates age and race
ethnicity standardized over these four
periods
um
hiv infected hiv uninfected
it's so it's counter deaths for a
hundred thousand person years okay
and you can see that throughout
the infected have a higher rate than the
uninfected
okay then this is the aids defining
cancers very low rate for the uninfected
decreasing
for the infected as you would as we
would expect during the art era
and then the non-aids defining cancers
still higher higher in the infected than
in the uninfected
okay so what are the basic conclusions
from this so cancer proportion mortality
among people living with hiv is
approaching that in the hiv uninfected
population it was still somewhat lower
but it was approaching
and cancer mortality rates are about 1.7
fold higher in hiv infected persons
compared to hiv uninfected persons
okay so we're seeing higher cancer
mortality rates
in hiv infected
okay so the the next point
people living with hiv have elevated
risk for many cancer types especially
those with viral etiology
okay
okay so this um i'm going to present
more uh results from the vex virtual
cohort so we're looking at
so far we looked at more just looking at
deaths mortality so now we're going to
look at cancer incidence
so to do this we linked
and this is um
work that i've done with leslie park
who's in the audience
we linked vax with the va central cancer
registry to obtain cancer diagnoses so
the va
has a basically a national cancer
registry that attempts to register every
single cancer case that's diagnosed or
treated in the va system
and then we calculated age sex race
ethnicity and calendar period
standardized incidence rate ratios
for hiv infected versus hiv uninfected
okay so i'm gonna um
just present some of these incidence
rate ratios
um
so first of all and i put i highlighted
in green the ones that were
statistically significant meaning the 95
confidence interval excluded uh
1.0
so
for all cancers combined
the incidence rate was about two-fold
higher for the hiv infected compared to
the hiv uninfected infected
now in terms of individual cancer types
oral cavity and pharynx was was somewhat
elevated
in ir 1.3
that's
a certain portion of those are related
to
human papilloma virus as a lot of you
probably know
okay anal cancer a very high irr of 28
also related to human papilloma virus
liver cancer 3.27
both eight hepatitis c virus and
hepatitis b virus
lung
no
known viral ideology but can anyone
guess why lung cancer might be elevated
particularly in hiv-infected people
yeah as we'll see later there's a high
prevalence of smoking
among hiv infected
although
it's a little bit of a side but it
actually looks like
the high prevalence of smoking
is one of the reasons but that
immunodeficiency is an independent risk
factor
for
lung cancer the reason not being
totally clear as it's more clear for the
viral infections
okay
right melanoma about a twofold elevated
risk
no known viral ideology
testicular cancer we see this in our
data
a number of cohorts have looked at
cancer incident cancer risk and hiv
infected looking at
infected versus uninfected it's not
testicular isn't always seen
but most of the ones that i've talked
about so far are pretty consistent with
the literature
then hodgkin's lymphoma pretty high of
irr of 9.
that's related to epstein-barr virus
we'd know about nhl we already talked
about nks
ir 519
so
so ks is extremely rare
in people who aren't infected with hiv
so this is you know a huge incident rate
ratio
and then leukemia there are some
leukemias that
that could be related to that could have
viral etiologies
okay so the conclusions from this part
um
so overall cancer incidence is about
twofold higher in infected compared to
unaffected veterans
right
as we not surprisingly people living
with hiv have elevated
incidence of aids defining cancers
but also um there's elevated incidence
of variety of non-aids defining cancer
types many of which have viral
ideologies
this is something that i mean this is
well appreciated now but it's something
that didn't become appreciated until
probably
between around 2005 or so like you know
people
used to think okay it's just those three
ace defining cancers that are an issue
for
hiv infected people but you know it
turns out that there are some that are
very high like the anal cancer
hydrogen's lymphoma some and and lung
cancer even though it's only a twofold
relative risk lung cancer is so common
that a two-filled relative risk is
really important in terms of public
health impact
all right
okay so now we're going to go on and
look at
in more detail about reasons for why we
see increased risk
so first
hiv infection itself
okay a little a little diversion first
um so just
um
so some of you may not be aware that the
immune apart from hiv the immune system
is very important in cancer
for two reasons or probably maybe more
than two reasons but one reason is that
it clears or suppresses oncogenic virus
infections
and secondly there's this phenomenon
that
was proposed a number of decades ago and
it became out of favor but now it's more
in favor again of cancer
immunosurveillance
meaning that the immune that we're
developing
nascent cancer cells in our bodies all
the time which the immune system largely
takes care of
if it's functioning well
okay so those are at least two
ways in which the immune system protects
against cancer but there's this other
phenomenon
that chronic immune activation and
inflammation actually promotes cancer
development and that's pretty well
established
um
and so the immune system's role in
cancer is kind of complicated on one
hand it's protecting on the other hand
you know if there's an inflammatory
process and immune activation it could
be promoting cancer
all right
all right so now i'm gonna um
show you some results briefly from what
was a seminal meta-analysis that
i and my group had nothing to do with
i'm presenting this as an as an
important paper
that was published in 2007 in lancet
and so they um looked at cancer
incidents in people with hiv
and compared that with people who were
immunosuppressed because they had were
organ transplant recipients
so who are routinely immunosuppressed so
they don't reject the transplant
um
so their reasoning was that the
lifestyle related risk factors
probably differ substantially between
those two groups like for example we
know that
as i've already mentioned that
hiv-infected people tend to have a high
prevalence of smoking
not necessarily true of transplant
patients
but the one thing that they had in
common is the immunodeficiency
okay so they reasoned okay if we see a
common kind of pattern of cancer
incidence in these two
immunosuppressed groups
um
it's likely that the reason for that is
is the immunodeficiency
so this was a meta-analysis they so they
had five
actually i showed the number on the next
slide
they had seven hiv aids cohorts and five
transplant cohorts
each of the cohort
cohorts was
what's called
in each of the cohorts they calculated
what are called standardized incidence
ratios
which is comparing
the rate of cancer
a particular cancer type in the cohort
with that in the general population
okay so they
they're one's able to get general
population rates from cancer registries
um and that and that's generally um how
they did this kind of study okay so
there were seven hiv aids five
transplant studies in this meta-analysis
um cohort size at in aggregate was much
larger for hiv aids and for the
transplant
pretty much
virtually all of the transplant patients
were renal transplant patients
all right
so here i um this is kind of my summary
of their results so let's walk through
this
uh
so these are cancer types that had a
significantly elevated standardized
incidence ratio which you could look at
as it's just another type of relative
risk it's the relative risk
um
in the
in the cohort compared to the general
population
um
okay so
for ks and
non-hazardous lymphoma
both
in the
hiv aids cohorts and in the transplant
cohorts
uh
the sir was greater than eight
so it's not not surprising uh
for for the hiv aids we already know
that those are aids to finding cancers
but that you see the same thing in
transplant recipients
so the so very similar pattern
both greater than four
for hodgkin's lymphoma
anus vulva and vagina penis non-melanoma
skin so i put in parentheses
uh
the virus
that either is known to cause these
types of cancer are suspected of causing
them so for non-melanoma skin for
example
uh one of the main types of non-melanoma
skin is squamous cell carcinoma of the
skin
and there's it's not proven but there's
evidence linking squamous cell carcinoma
in the skin to hpv virus at least for a
portion of those
okay then both greater than two
we have liver cervix oral cavity and
fairings lip
larynx eye
lung multiple myeloma and leukemia
and both greater than one and a half we
have esophagus stomach h pylori is a
type of bacteria that's known
to cause stomach cancer
and kidney but all the rest of these are
viruses
and then finally both greater than 1.2
melanoma
so
so that's basically a summary of the
grueling
article and the conclusions we might
draw are many cancer types had increased
incidents in both groups
most are known or suspected viral
ideology
i didn't show this but they saw no in
each of these groups there was no
increase in breast cancer
or in prostate cancer okay
now you might have thought there might
have been an increased incidence of
those cancers in these groups because
they're both under very close medical
surveillance right they're they're in
the medical system
um
seeing doctors more likely to be
screened therefore more likely for the
cancers to be diagnosed the fact that
they weren't suggests that um we can't
explain the other increases there was
that we're seeing based on medical
surveillance
so the
as they uh as
according to the reasoning i showed in
the beginning
when i started talking about this the
most likely explanation for the
elevated risk of these many cancer types
is immunodeficiency in these two groups
okay so now i'm going to show a little
more of our own data
so
some simple measures of immune function
in hiv infection one of course is cd4
cell count which is kind of a you know
that's what the virus attacks that's why
there's immune deficiency because the
lower cd4 cell counts and then secondly
hiv viral load
that's looking at hiv rna copies in the
blood
and that's actually a rough measure of
chronic immune activation and
inflammation
it's not perfect but it's something to
look at
all right
so i'm going to show some results
on cd4 and hiv rna in relation to ks
risk
in the north american aids cohort
collaboration on research and design
known as na accord
okay so this is a
big cohort collaboration
vax is actually a member of this cohort
collaboration
consists of more than 20 hiv cohorts
the na court got a lot of
money back in 2009 from
from ara
to validate cancer diagnoses in all of
these cohorts so they were validated
either by chart review or by cancer
registry linkage so these are good data
about cancer
and then the ana accord data center
which is located in johns hopkins
does a lot of work to kind of harmonize
the data from these more than 20 cohorts
into a single data set which is a lot of
work because people collect data in
different ways and
variables are defined differently so you
have to kind of sort all that out
okay so in this particular analysis
there were 15 cohorts that contributed
data
total n was
almost 65 000
among
that end these are all hiv
all of the everyone in this cohort is
hiv infected
689 ks cases arose
over a median follow-up of 6.2 years
okay
we calculated hazard ratios using cox
proportional hazardous models
hazard ratios are the same
as
incidence rate ratios so just think of
them again as a relative risk
these models were adjusted for age sex
race ethnicity cohort
calendar period of entry into the cohort
hiv risk group you know such as
injection drug use etc and baseline
art
all right
so
this is looking at baseline cd4 in
relation to ks risk baseline cd4 is the
cd4 count at entry into the cohort and
then you look we're looking at that as a
predictor of future ks risk
um
so these are our hazard ratios
um see our reference group is 500 plus
cd4 cell count
um
looking at different cd4 categories
so is this some
does this impress you that cd4 count is
a is a really strong predictor of
of ks risk
just curious if you think this is
impressive
okay no one wants to commit um well so i
don't i don't think it's very impressive
right but there's a no we could so let's
think about is there another way we
could look at cd4 count um
this is just looking at taking a single
cd4 count at baseline and then saying
okay no matter how far we power that
forward does that predict
ks risk another way to look at it is to
have our exposure of interest be the cd4
count six months previously
so in other words we keep as you [ __ ]
follow the cohort forward you keep time
updating the cd4 count to use the cd4
count that occurred six months in the
past
okay so we do the analysis that way
um this is what it looks like
so it's this is impressive
um you know when you start seeing hazard
ratios of 45
you know that's a pretty high risk
and so
i wanted to show these data but also
make the point that it's important to
think about you know how you define
your exposure
now we did the same thing
we looked at baseline hiv rna in
relation to ks risk
so we're less than 500 was our reference
category
um 100 000 plus was our highest category
again not real impressive
but then we did the time updated hiv rna
and again now we're seeing much more
impressive
um hazard ratios
okay then and so then the next thing we
did was put them want to ask
okay these are in separate models so
this is a model with hiv rna adjusting
for the factors
adjusting for these factors but it
doesn't have didn't have cd4 count in
the model
and this model didn't have hiv rna in
the model okay so now let's put them
together simultaneously in the same
model adjusting for all those risk
factors
and
so we can see that there's some mutual
confounding but we're still seeing
pretty strong independent effects of cd4
count and hiv rna so in our less than 50
category we're seeing a hazard ratio of
almost 20
and our 100 000 plus
hiv rna category we're seeing a hazard
ratio
of
almost 10.
so
another way of looking at that there
being independent risk factors if
someone
has a cd4 less than 50
and also has
hiv rna greater than 100 000
their risk would be about let's say 20
times 10 or they'd have a hazard ratio
of about 200
okay so so they're independent risk
factors
so conclusions um from this
well i already made this conclusion time
updated measures of cd4 and hiv vrna
must be used
to assess these covariates in relation
to risk of ks and by implication of
other cancer types as well
and both recent cd4 count and recent hiv
rna level were strong independent
predictors of ks risk
okay so that's
so that's um not too surprising so if we
go back to this natural history here um
so
we know that so ks is a is defining
cancer
and that's in the period when we're our
hiv rna is is is going up
a period of aids
and our cd4 counts are going way down
so you know so this is why it's defining
cancer um you know it's pretty clear
based on the data that i just showed
okay so in another study um
this was a study that i was involved in
that michael silverberg at kaiser led
so this is kaiser permanente in northern
california so they have a big hiv cohort
and
in this particular study there were more
than 20 000 hiv infected and 10 times
that amount of hiv uninfected
these are our mean observation times for
this particular study
in this study we calculated rate ratios
from poisson regression so um
often plus
foisan models and cox models
actually you'll get exactly the same
results
um
so mike really likes poisson models so i
like cox models better but he was the
leader on this so we use the poisson
models
so
but this gives us rate ratios
and we did time updated measures again
six month lag
and adjusted for these various factors
including some cancer risk factors like
smoking
overweight obesity and alcohol
use
okay and just to briefly summarize these
data
um
so these are this is with mutual
adjustment
of hiv rna and cd4
as well as adjusting for the
covariance listed on the previous slide
um
so we see for hiv rna and this is uh
uh
risks for different cancer selected
cancer types all non-nate's defining
cancers
um
so for hiv rna we're looking at greater
or equal to 10 000 versus less than 500
copies
and you see there's really not much
going on here so none of these results
were statistically significant
for cd4 count less than equal to 200
versus 500 plus
we're seeing
elevated
rate ratios for
anal hodgkin's lymphoma oral cavity
pharynx
liver
not prostate lung is kind of borderline
and colorectal
so seeing it for a number of different
this wasn't a comp this didn't look at
like every cancer type comprehensively
mike wanted to look at selected cancer
types in this particular paper so but
most of them
are related to low cd4 count
okay so that's basically what this says
the low recent cd4 count was associated
with increased risk of a variety of 9
a's defining cancers
and there was no compelling evidence
that high recent hiv rna is
independently associated with
not risk of non-aids defining cancers
now this is one study there are some
other studies that do implicate
hiv rna at least in some
non-aids-defining cancers
yeah that's interesting okay so you
wouldn't have neces let me
so we're seeing um this for colorectal
cancer um which you wouldn't have
necessarily expected because um
so there are a few possibilities one is
just that it's you know
random
uh just a random finding that doesn't
mean anything this most most studies
have not found colorectal cancer to be
elevated among hiv-infected people
another possibility
which i think is intriguing
so i've been focusing on
the aspect of the immune system that
suppresses viral infections and
therefore
you know in hiv infection the viral
virus associated cancers have
elevated risk
now a cancer like colorectal cancer or
breast or prostate cancer it's they
develop over many many years
you know decades
and
the way that they would be related
could be related to hiv are number one
the inflammation because those cancers
there's good evidence that those that
inflammation does increase the risk of
those cancers including colorectal
and secondly
is the cancer immunosurveillance
and if that
you know so if that's the way that the
body normally controls colorectal cancer
over the long run
you know if that's
impaired over the long run we might see
elevated risk for colorectal cancer
which maybe hasn't really maybe is just
starting to emerge or hasn't emerged yet
because
we're only
less than two decades really
into the
antiretroviral therapy era
right so that's one of the things that i
think people want to look for will these
other cancers start emerging as being
elevated um
yeah but this is just one study so it's
hard to really say
okay so now so next
high prevalence of non-hiv cancer risk
factors so what are we talking about
here so
i listed modifiable cancer risk factors
and cancer types to which they're known
to be associated so i didn't actually in
this one i didn't list suspected just
known yeah
so um
they're matched on va site though the
yeah so
that's pretty much taken care of yeah so
like if it's the new york va then the
hiv
uninfected are coming from new york va
um
okay so
um
as you know smoking about 30 of um
overall cancer deaths are due to smoking
so that's the really big one
but alcohol is a risk factor for these
cancers well-established obesity
and we've already talked about viral
infections
and so
what i've listed here is so this is
prevalence of some of these risk factors
in the general population compared to
persons living with hiv
so
and this though so these these are
ranges this obviously
people living with hiv are you know a
heterogeneous group and these ranges
come from
different recent studies
uh that have looked at prevalence of
various risk factors
uh
so about this the smoking is really
striking because even the lowest one is
twice as high as the general population
and then there are some you know some
groups of people living with hiv with
extremely high
smoking prevalence
mainly injection drug users actually
okay alcohol is kind of difficult to
figure out because
there are so many different measures
that are used in different studies of
hazardous alcohol consumption but i
listed it because it is an important
risk factor and and
the thinking is that overall alcohol
consumption is higher among people
living with hiv especially injection
drug users
okay obesity is one where actually the
prevalence is lower
although it's
since the advent of art it's kind of
been coming up
in hiv infected
because we no longer have
you know the hiv wasting syndrome which
would do the opposite is now much more
better controlled
um
cervical hpv is pretty common in the
general population of women
but it's it's definitely higher among
people living with hiv
anal
couldn't find anything about
the overall general population
men who have sex with with men have a
high prevalence of anal hpv but even
higher in
people living with hiv
oral uh
general population four to ten percent
20 to 47
in hiv infected
and then also higher prevalence of
hepatitis b virus and of hepatitis c
virus infections
hcv is extremely high in injecting drug
users because
it's that's a very easy way to transmit
it
all right
so um so there is so the point is that
there is a high prevalence of non-hiv
cancer risk factors overall
among people living with hiv
okay so now the final point that i'll
make in the last five minutes or so
is
approaches to cancer prevention
which i listed earlier early art
reduction and the prevalence of these
cancer risk factors and screening so
let's go through those briefly so does
early art reduce cancer risk
so
the only way to really prove that it
does would be to conduct a randomized
trial
where you randomize people to have early
art or
or later art and then compared cancer
incidents but that's not going to happen
so we have to go by other arguments
so first biological evidence you know
what the known effects of art we know
that it suppresses viral load increases
cd4 count
and that it reduces immune activation
and inflammation
so we could kind of we could you know
make that jump well okay that means if
we're if our cd4 counts are improving
then we're probably doing better with
regard to cancer
secondly there is increasing evidence
from observational epidemiology that
early art will reduce cancer risk
as i said there's no randomized
evidence uh with regard to this question
but also we the the question is is an
academic question um because
in the at least in the united states at
least it's already recommended that
people start art as early as possible
that's something that's evolved over the
last few years it wasn't always the case
because there are some downsides to
taking art you know the toxicity etc
but the current recommendation
so for those with high cd4 cell counts
i'm this is quoting from the panel
that makes the recommendations
whose short-term risk of death may be
low the recommendation to initiate art
is based on growing evidence that
untreated hiv infection or uncontrolled
viremia is associated with development
of non-aids defining diseases including
cardiovascular disease kidney disease
liver disease neurologic complications
and malignancies that's my emphasis
furthermore newer art regimens are more
effective more convenient and better
tolerated than regimens used in the past
so the judgment of the panel
is that
to control these non-aids conditions
um it's important to start art as early
as impossible as possible you know which
gets into a lot of issues about the
importance of you know early diagnosis
that it's not
you know a lot of people are still
aren't i aren't diagnosed with hiv
infection until they start developing
opportunistic infections which is late
in the game
um
so in any event early art is prob you
know the odds are that it's very
important in cancer prevention although
the only way to prove it would be with a
randomized study
okay secondly reduction in prevalence of
non-hiv cancer risk factors
so there's work people who are
interested in behavioral approach you
know interventions in hiv and people
living with hiv might think about this
because there's a lot of work that needs
to be done
in terms of targeted interventions
so it's not you know
for a number of reasons if you think
about smoking
um
cessation
you know it's not that easy for anyone
to stop smoking because nicotine is so
addictive but then on top of that you
know you have
um
co-occurrence of of
alcohol use you could have co-occurrence
of drug use it just became becomes very
difficult
problem but it's important not just
smoking cessation is important not just
for cancer but as you know it's an
important risk factor for non-malignant
respiratory disease for heart disease
and for other conditions
so target interventions particularly for
smoking i think um would be really
helpful
um
so i kind of mentioned that and then
vaccination certainly it's already
recommended that
hiv-infected people
be vaccinated against hpv virus if
they're not already infected with the
virus
there's some evidence that vaccination
might be helpful against hpv even if
you've had a previous um even if you've
been infected previously that needs a
lot more work
um
so there's opportunities actually be for
people interested in behavioral
interventions the vaccination one is
also very important
there's the issue of adherence
because both of those
require three vaccinations
you know so people are going to come
back for the second and third
there are issues of efficacy because of
the immuno
deficiency you know how well of the
vaccination is really going to work
that's not a behavioral issue but the
adherences
and then treatment of hpv and hcv so
with hcv in particular
historically the treatment has been
really bad abysmal
in terms of
uptake and results
just very tight you know treatments
somewhat toxic they take a long time
but
last
a year or two there was
two new drugs were approved and there
are several other
important new drugs in the pipeline that
are expected to revolutionize treatment
of hcv
and so that's something to really look
for in the next um number you know next
five years or so and that could be
really important for hiv-infected
persons to try to clear hcv
all right
and then finally
cancer screening
so if people have a with people with a
sufficient life expectancy it's pretty
clear that cervical cancer
breast cancer and colorectal cancer
screening would be beneficial
for people living with hiv
um anyone know why i say with sufficient
life expectancy
why don't we just screen everyone
so um
typical person who's who's diagnosed
with with one of these cancers
um
if they only have a two year let's say
they only have a two year life
expectancy there's probably no point in
knowing you know if you're asympto
screening by definition means that
you're asymptomatic
um there's probably no point in knowing
that you know it's probably do more harm
than good to know that you have that
cancer because you're going to be dying
of something else anyway and the cancer
may never cause any kinds of problems so
typically like so like for example for
colorectal cancer screening
the recommendation not just for hiv in
fact but for everyone is that you only
get screened if you have at least a 10
year life expectancy
because it takes you know it's a slow
growing it takes long to develop
okay so then more research is needed to
determine the benefits versus harms for
other screening so one is anal cancer
um
which could be very important um you
know this as i showed the the risk for
anal cancer is very high um
but we don't know if cytology or high
resolution enoscopy really does any good
um so um you're probably having
in fe1 you probably haven't gotten into
screening yet am i right about that
you talked about screening in fb1 some
any of you taking everyone a little bit
um
but you'll that you'll get it those of
you who take epi too
you'll get you'll learn fairly
thoroughly about screening um
and and what a lot of people don't
appreciate is that
you know
the intuition would be okay why not
screen if you could if you could find
the cancer early you might as well do it
but it turns out that there are a lot of
harms to screening
that aren't
generally appreciated the most important
of which is probably
if there are a lot of false positives so
people have false positives go on to get
now they're in the medical system they
get more tests which are invasive then
those tests could harm them
you know if they if they're false
positives they didn't they had nothing
to worry about in the first place but
they're having all these potential harms
so in any event it's important to show
for any screening to show that there's
more benefit than harm and for hiv
infected patients
it's actually not known for anal cancer
for lung cancer
there's a a big push on now to screen
smokers using low dose ct
whether that would also be beneficial
you know you have to do a different kind
of
benefit versus harm analysis in hiv
infected patients because there are
particularities to that um
and actually i have a colleague who got
an r1 grant who's doing that kind of
analysis right now
liver cancer there's no um
a lot of liver people do liver cancer
really push screening but there's really
no evidence at this point that it does
any good it might do i'm not saying it
doesn't it might but we don't know one
way or the other
even people are hiv uninfected but this
is it's an important issue in the hiv
infected
if you because liver cancer is becoming
more and more important due to
high prevalence of co-infection with hcv
and hpv becoming more and more important
in the hiv population so this is an
important area of research
all right
so then to summarize
going back to my early slide that i keep
showing
cancer is a major cause of morbidity and
mortality in people living with hiv aids
they have an elevated risk for many
cancer types especially those with a
viral etiology and that's due to hiv
infection itself
and to a high prevalence of non-hiv
cancer risk factors
cancer prevention among people living
with hiv aids
includes
almost certainly early art
reduction in prevalence of non-hiv
cancer risk factors and screening for
selected cancer types and there's a lot
of
important
both public health practice work and
research that needs to be done i think
in this area
any i'll take any questions
oh okay elaine well actually
and it's about smoking
on again but it happens at the um i'm
serving on the connecticut tobacco
settlement board and i mentioned this
because
we recommended funding smoking cessation
relapse prevention in the correctional
system and it's a very innovative
program going on now
we did a survey in a number of
facilities
and spoken prevalence and this
population was like 70 to 90
and they went
right
to find populations with high prevalence
right
so yeah
it's a good question we're good yeah
we will
no we didn't do it i was thinking that
when i was presenting this we really
should look at the interaction right
okay good question so the incubation
period i don't think that's
so it's hard to define the incubation
period because i mean once you're
infected with the virus you know most a
lot of people are infected their whole
life and they don't develop
sarcoma so
i mean that's an interaction right um
you know if you don't have composer so
if you're not infected with a virus
doesn't matter how low your cd4 count
goes
or your hiv rna how high it goes you're
not going to develop kaposi sarcoma um
the other hand if you're infected with
the virus but your your immune system
remains strong you're not going to
develop it it's only the interaction
but it's hard to define like what is
but the way we picked the six months
actually i didn't show this but we
looked at different lags
we looked at six three we looked at six
months 12 months 24 months 48 months and
um
that was the best one
that's the one that was most predictive
it was the best model
so
it may be it's probably more complicated
so this is kind of work in progress so
what we're studying right where we're
looking at right now
is um i'll just talk about cd4 but we're
looking at the same thing with the viral
load we're looking at the slope of the
change we want to see if a rapid decline
you know is an independent predictor
if you have the slope plus the six-month
lag in the model and then we're looking
at
um
the proportion of time below
a threshold um so let's say over the
past four years
yeah that's right and so we want to see
which of then put all that together and
figure out what's
yeah how much is cumulative how much you
know is the reason what's most important
yeah
okay
so it's one o'clock i don't want to keep
people past